whether you're the reigning squat
champion of the wall market or you're
dipping your toes into the live stream
for the first time Final Fantasy 7
remake is bound to overwhelm with its
deceptively intricate combat system and
steamiest
of steampunk world design thankfully
we've put together a brief visitor's
guide for everyone on board this train
getting off at the seventh and final
stop here are seven tips to make your
time in Midgar whether it's your first
trip or your glorious homecoming all the
more accommodating clouds are Material
Girl first off you should be equipping
every material orb you find early on
gaining experience from killing enemies
and using spells levels up each piece of
materia you have equipped which allows
you to cast more powerful versions of
them for example the spells Blizzard
becomes blazar ax Phi becomes fira and Q
becomes Kyra
you should invest in levelling up spell
materia as there some of these strongest
attacks in the game and if you send a
single spell into a cluster of enemies
you can sometimes kill two birds with
one stone
well you know a stone of materia it's
smart to equip everyone with healing
materia so that you always have someone
to help throw down in a pinch and
sticking specific characters with either
Thunder Blizzard or fire so you know
who's a TB bars to save for exploiting
an enemy's weakness most enemies are
usually weak to one of the three so it
helps to be prepared for anything even
if you don't end up using some of them
in the end leveled up materia orbs are
some of the most valuable items in the
game so you're welcome to sell the ones
you've stopped using to various shop
keeps to get your fill of Gil one final
note be sure to purchase the barrier
material as soon as possible you get
this later on while progressing through
the game as well but you'll want to
start leveling it up as soon as possible
not only is it clutch's an early game
defence bonus against physical attacks
but it's super helpful once you turn it
into man award to half incoming magic
damage so you can start taking on the VR
challenges to unlock summons y'all
better accessorize speaking of leveling
up materia the best way to do so is to
have as many material slot available on
each character as possible even if
you're low on Gil once you get to sector
7 be sure to purchase some iron bangles
or star bracelets from the weapon shop
to expose
your available material Ott's of course
these bump up your defense as well but
the goal is to equip more materia once
you complete a few side missions you
should have enough kill to purchase
armor upgrades for Cloud Barrett and
Tifa so don't be stingy with your
earnings don't neglect your side mesh
but gamespot you might say I don't want
to do the side missions I just want to
experience the story well have I got
good news for you Billy the side
missions are the story completing side
missions is a win-win for everyone
involved first they're a great
opportunity to spend individual time
with characters like Tifa which adds to
the rich history of clouds friendship
with her second you get some pretty
serious materia equipment and weapon
upgrades if you take the time to
mitigate the concerns of Midgar ian's
while some of these might have you
running around the streets like a slum
cat millionaire be sure to place extra
care into helping out Shinra intern
extraordinaire sadly he will give the
assessment area scan some enemies in
battle for him and he'll use the data
you collect to create new material for a
low price and give you access to special
VR missions to unlock summoning spells
upload your attacks to the cloud as
you'll quickly learn during early
encounters combat is a mix of action and
turn-based decision-making
while on easier modes smashing that
square button might be enough to get by
but enemy encounters and bosses later on
will knock you out faster than LL Cool J
if you don't heed the potential of the
games full mechanics first make sure
you're actively switching to your
character's alternate attacks by using
the triangle button cloud switches into
his slower Punisher mode stance which
increases his damage and stagger output
on the other hand Barret unleashes a
powerful charge shot while Tifa strikes
with a jaw breaking uppercut second try
to always have your eye on each
character's ATB meters on the
bottom-right of the screen while you
should maintain awareness of everyone's
HP generally you should actively pay
attention to when you can use your
party's abilities as much as possible if
you're focusing on cloud who's currently
up close and personal with an opponent
hit the l2 or r2 buttons to quickly add
a command to the queue so Tifa can send
in a blizzard spell or Barret can heal
up his spiky haired bro on the frontline
character ATB meters charge slower if
you're not direct
controlling them to attack so be sure to
jump around from time to time to make
sure you're personally engaging with
them in the current fight dodge this
there's a materia you get early on
called deadly dodge it allows you to
quickly pull off an area of effect
physical attack after performing a dodge
I recommend giving this to cloud
immediately not only does he have the
strongest physical attack in the early
game but because you control him in
fights first by default and you want him
up close delivering damage you can stop
most fights by rolling straight into the
fray no luck plus materia required here
as you slice and dice your foes spec
yourself before you wreck yourself
once biggs and wedge teach you how to
upgrade your weapons you'll want to take
advantage of fleshing out your
characters attributes every time you get
a new weapon once you've better
familiarized yourself with the combat
system and your party's individual
strengths and weaknesses try to build
out their specs to match a role in a
fight if you want my recommendations I
like leveling up clouds strengths
bonuses as a primary damage dealer teef
is ability to stagger Barrett's ability
to deal tank damage and aerith's
strengths as a mage in the back row with
this configuration a typical encounter
with a mini-boss might play out in the
following way cloud rushes forward
switching to punish a mode to lay down
some damage Tifa builds up her APB with
standard attacks and then uses the
unbridled strength ability to increase
the enemy stagger meter and then Barret
casts thunder and takes potshots from
the back once the enemy is staggered and
susceptible to damage cloud can then use
a strong attack like braver to deal
massive damage
Tifa can pull off her beefed-up combos
and Barret can take care of any healing
that the party might need if you need a
boost on stat points be sure to smash
every shinrock crate and open every
chest you see as well they'll sometimes
drop mughal medals which you can use
later on to buy stat upgrades or for
specific characters block enemies from
damaging you lastly here are some
general tips for combat as tempting as
it may be to see those damage numbers
fly be on the lookout for any telltale
signs that enemies exhibit when they're
about to wind up a powerful attack and
try to block or dodge out of the way
with cloud you might want to consider
blocking a successfully blocking a
physical attack
second we'll lower the amount of damage
you take while also delivering a modest
counter-attack some bosses and
mini-bosses almost require you to block
and dodge to build up their stagger
meters so be mindful of what works best
in the given combat situation also
during boss fights and don't be afraid
to get too liberal with healing spells
and items things can go from bad to
worse really quickly if one of your
party members gets knocked out of a
fight requiring precious ATB bars to
give them a Phoenix Town and another to
cure them some bosses occasionally pull
off random attacks that do massive
damage which can easily wipe out a
character if they're resting comfortably
with three-quarters of their health
remaining if you're going to heal though
make sure you've got enough distance
between yourself and the monster that's
trying to hit you if you're damaged
during the casting animation not only
will it not going to affect you'll lose
the ATB meats that you attempted to use
these are just a few tips to help you
get started on the final fantastical
journey ahead of you what are some
things you realize too late is there
anything we missed otherwise we hope
you're enjoying this long-awaited remake
as much as we are happy hunting my
avalanche inductees
[Music]